une plateforme pour mutualiser les
trajets des activités extra scolaires
des enfants le principe de qui drive ou
mettre en lien des parents à proximité
la plateforme geo callies les parents
qui sont proches de chez vous pour
pouvoir covoiturer qu accompagner en
fonction du monde de transport souhaité
des horaires des jours etc qui sont
renseignés dans la plateforme du coup
entre parents l'application est parti
d'un besoin ressenti par la fondatrice
mme annick oise mère de deux enfants
chacun participé à une activité
différente en même temps il s'avère que
je pouvais pas que vos flacons voiture
et mes deux enfants à 15 minutes
d'intervalle et à 5 kilomètres de
différence du coup j'ai eu cette idée de
pouvoir accompagner entre parents de
confiance c'était vraiment important
pour moi pour gérer mes enfants maman
d'une famille recomposée difficile pour
vinciane de gérer les activités de
chacun une fois par semaine depuis le
mois de septembre une qui drivait emmène
son fils à son cours de dessin un trajet
en moins pour la maman le fait de ne pas
avoir un si grand qu'on va voir mardi il
faut que je parte plutôt parce qu'il a
des seins ou alors un ballon là j'ai une
réunion c'est galère ben là je peux pas
y aller machin non je sais que j'ai
toujours quelqu'un qui va y aller moi ça
me permet d'avoir une amplitude plus
large pour mes horaires de travail ce
jour là donc c'est enfin c'est
clairement en terme de logistique dans
la tête d'une maman qui peut être très
très très lourde c'est ce et voilà c'est
très très confortable qui drive vous est
lancé depuis juin 2021 le service
pourrait s'élargir prochainement pour
inclure les trajets d'école